hi guys it's silver at again and this is
mine for this video using this new
microphone so hi is my voice with my new
microphone in case you haven't heard it
yet
and this is just going to be a very
small episode mainly because I just had
this one recorded file lying around on
my computer and I just had to release it
I just had to do a little commentary
over it and get that thing out of the
way because I want to record on my new
computer from now on I've actually just
recorded some let's play footage and
that actually went very well the only
thing is my fraps file that I eventually
ended up with is 160 gigs and also yeah
right for some reason the ambient
occlusion started disappearing and
that's another thing that I would like
to talk about because ambient occlusion
is awesome but I am not sure whether
it's actually going to work and I try to
mess around with settings and stuff and
eventually just decided to go with one
setting because many of the settings
didn't even work but for some reason
this setting doesn't work in some cases
like it just crashed in my let's play
park after a while and silver City is
also a weird case because for some
reason in Silver City it doesn't work
when I point the camera towards a
certain place on the map and that's
actually the little work crossing with
the gift or bookshop or whatever that
thing is supposed to be there the little
one with their two office buildings with
the glassy towers on both sides and I
don't know why it does that but for some
reason when I point the camera towards
that place I mean seclusion doesn't work
and in any other case it works fine but
yeah this video itself is just going to
be pretty simple it's really just me
building this this building and
duplicating it I just felt like making a
small simple building and I felt like
this is a general shape that I'm
somewhat used to and just wanted to see
if it would actually work in Silver City
as well now what you see over here is
actually my second try of doing this I
also had a first try and that took me a
whole lot of time and I ended up with a
building that I did not like at all so I
decided to do it again and I kind of
liked the result of this however the
more I look at this city the more I look
at that city the more I realize that it
is somewhat of a small skill and it's
not that detailed as in if I really
finish this
it might just be I'm pretty sure it is
the most detailed city and the most
in-depth city that I've actually seen
anyone built in Rana Coast I can three
but then again it's not really the way
that I really like it in in turn in well
I don't pay as much attention to details
on every single building as I usually do
with theme parks and perhaps the only
way to actually build a full-scale
realistic city or at least a part of it
would be to do that because as you can
see the buildings are somewhat
simplistic in their appearance they just
basically shells yeah the basically
shells this is this is North Korea guys
we are trying to build silver city
across the border of South Korea to
impress all of that all of the
capitalistic countries and the Imperial
[ __ ] and stuff like that so that's that
Silver City now you know that true
identity behind the shells of the
buildings and speaking of shells this
building is quite weird in that sense
because it has a glass roof and why does
it have a glass roof you might ask and
at first I didn't want to go with the
glass roof I just needed a roof that
would fit on this weird shape that I had
on top and it seemed like none of the
sets that I had would fit on it and I
didn't even know for sure if there are
any said to actually work with this so I
just decided to go with the only set
that I knew could actually do this and
that would be Moby's Glass Works and
globe movies glass house and frameworks
I think that's what it's called
yeah so that's why I did this so yeah in
the end it's overall a pretty nice
looking building but it's again it's
somewhat simple in its appearance it's
inspired by for any of you Dutch peep
out there I know is actually a very
small minority of my videos but I'll
talk about that in a minute but yeah
this is inspired by um the haftorah in
the egg so that's that's cool I guess
but yeah I expected actually that a
major part of my audience is Dutch but
it's not that way it's actually the
third largest the United States is by
far the biggest part of my audience it's
I like I mean I think it's probably
actually about 35%
of the total and it's more than twice as
big as the second largest audience in
the UK so all you guys are awesome and
then I'm further down the list there's
Netherlands I think I don't know it
exactly by heart but it's something
along lines of Netherlands Germany
France and Belgium Sweden actually I
think is pretty high up in the list but
I'm not entirely sure and some other
surprising countries like Japan I never
really I never even knew that roller
coaster can three was even alive in
Japan like I've never actually seen
someone from Japan in the community
pretty plenty of people from like not
well noise but what South Korea and even
Taiwan so that's really awesome but no
one from Japan so but yeah they are
there and that's all cool so actually I
think there are a total of about 180
nationalities and well so that would be
my subscribers then so that is really
awesome I guess yeah that is really cool
that's all my subscribers by the way
that's my viewers subscribers are
probably only from like 50 different
countries but it's all thanks to YouTube
being awesome that you can look at that
I think no matter how small you can your
channel is you can look at that but I'm
not entirely sure of that it's really
cool though I don't know why I'm talking
about this but it's just something that
I find very interesting and very awesome
just about this world that we live that
we live in it like people all over the
world and we can all well yeah play
roller coast I can three and I'm here
sitting in my room talking to a
microphone talking to a screen which is
currently showing this skyscraper being
built by the me of a couple of days ago
sometimes the world can be very strange
though it's normal in that sense huh
where's even strange but yeah the city
isn't too strange no definitely not
figured this building does fit into the
skyline the only thing that I'm very
afraid of right now is the fact that
because of the limited amount of sets
that I'm using for this they are all
starting to turn out like kind of like
the same buildings and that's why I am
currently on a hunt for many more well
generic modern building sets
and I've found a couple but not too many
yet so I kind of want to continue the
hunt I've seen many amazing buildings
being built by people and I definitely
want to try and see if there's any other
custom scenery sets that I really need
to build modern buildings and there's
actually also a different plan that I
had it's something that I've been
planning for about for quite a while
actually right now but it's something
that I just randomly thought of again
today and I realized that it's actually
something that I'd like to try out it's
to rebuild a part of Rotterdam even
though I'm not a big fan of it I don't
even like it at all I think there are
pretty nice places in Rotterdam and I
feel like it might be worth giving a
shot in my let's play to actually try
and recreate a part of Rotterdam and
just kind of see how close we can get it
because I don't think that anyone's ever
really recreated a city or at least the
point of a city in Monaco second three
as closely as possible so I want to give
that a shot
even though I've always said I'm against
recreations like rollercoasters and all
that because it doesn't really involve
creativity I kind of want to see how far
I can get with making Rotterdam and then
see if I can place like some sample
buildings that I've designed myself in
it and see how that looks but anyway
that's that's this episode so thank you
all for watching and see you in the next
one